[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport c'est le cinquième numéro
deux cette saison sur tb 78 au programme
comme toujours une dose de bonne humeur
des années e-sportive et surtout des
coups de gueule et des à débat nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite vous le connaissez
à tous c'est un pistard de niveau
international il a d'ailleurs été
champion du monde de cyclisme sur piste
master ci n'a pas sa langue dans sa
poche il aime aller au bout de ses idées
on le surnomme le capitaine yann
dujarrier est avec nous on sent qu'il ya
une heure quand allez-vous super à
hubert quand on met lass tâche à petit
la mission petite moustache c'est un
petit hommage à un ami cycliste qui a
disparu en 2019 du d'un cancer de la
prostate et c'est vrai que je pense que
ces deux villes de vue du club de vélizy
web michel barraud c'était un vraiment
un ami et
il me manque et il est toujours toujours
présent avec moi maintenant mon
quotidien donc moustache moustache
chômage tout alors on continue notre
tour de table musique c'est une
véritable encyclopédie sion du sport
local il connaît tout sur tout c'est
notamment un spécialiste football en
corée le surnommer les luttes mais on le
surnomme dans cette émission l'italian
lover grégory canal et de tv 78 étaient
avec nous bonjour michel on compare à
neo dans matrix exactement que vous êtes
l'élu écouter chanter ou très bien très
bien on est installé les jours commence
à devenir un peu plus froid mais on est
paré pour s'entraîner pour ça vous allez
débattre ou les acheteurs voilà cette
émission exactement même s'il fait très
chaud dans ce bateau mais on va faire
monter la température on continue à ma
droite musique c'est notre spécialiste
en rugby
mais il s'y connaît dans tous les sports
c'est un peu notre couteau suisse on le
surnomme le gladiateur tant il aime
batailler pour ses idées pierre
chevalier du rugby-club de versailles et
avec le samu à tous salle unique aux
parents moustache aussi pour le maroc
sur le move amber voyager pas tout
tendre et là j'ai eu interdiction de ma
fille d'enlever la barbe donc on
travaille quand même la moustache un peu
fleuri en cette période où on
effectivement on est en hommage à la
recherche contre les contre les cancers
masculins donc voilà on marque le coup
ces sportifs et ses essais c'est pour la
bonne cause le message est passé en tout
cas on termine à ma gauche musique c'est
notre chouchou des qu'ils participent à
cette émission allez forcément
excellente il adore les duels et il aime
glisser le temps en temps quelques
blagues avec un sourire malicieux
mesdames et messieurs je demande le
silence sur ce plateau jean miss
ex-coach de plaisir est avec nous
pendant une heure bonsoir michael moss
aura tous comment allez-vous j'en ai
toujours pareil mon plein bourg qu'un
nouveau sourire malicieux encore
aujourd'hui gross 61 ans de traque qui
le drame qu'ils ont reçus petite
moustache et la moustache et la gestion
de l'eau et un col roulé vous vous avez
la chemise ouverte
un beau soleil alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission va tout de suite
prendre la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour parler tennis
de table un tournoi international
handisport est programmée cette semaine
mardi mercredi et jeudi au gymnase des
pyramides le rendez vous organisé par le
club skipping réuni 26 pays venus de
tous les continents et des médailles et
paralympiques et c'est une grande
première pour le club réaction au micro
de tv 78 c'est une première on n'a pas
fait de tournée en france depuis 2014 où
ça s'était pas très bien passé et en
fait avec paris 2024
on devait faire un tournoi en france et
là c'est lui c'est on va dire un des
premiers tournois sachant que je pense
que si ça se passe très bien les gens
voudront venir et là il ya des très très
bon joueur
alors le club espère organiser à nouveau
ce type de compétition dans les
prochaines années votre avis tout
simplement sur ce tournoi positive pour
vous il ya déjà raillé mois ayant ayant
eu la chance de pouvoir participer à un
championnat du monde de cyclisme sur
piste handisport en tant que pilote d'un
hat est malvoyant qui a été médaillé de
bronze aux jeux de aux jeux de tokyo a
fait la plus vieille france a permis
voilà j'ai découvert une
une ambiance une ambiance extra sportif
parce que voilà oui bien sûr qu'ils se
déplacent pour faire du sport et ce sont
des vrais athlètes qui s'entraînent
autant que des athlètes valides mais
mais en plus à côté de ça il sait des
leçons de vie au quotidien c'est à dire
que io qu'ils ont des handicaps mais
mais ils le vivent avec le sourire et
c'est génial quand on voit des gens
valides parfois se plaindre pour pour
certains petit mot
qui n'ont pas lieu d'être ben voilà
rencontrer ces gens là eh bien eh bien
c'est c'est simplement être enfin
ensuite être capable de relativiser des
petites périodes de la vie qui va être
un peu compliqué eux vivent leur
handicap au quotidien et il s'en est il
utilise avec
parfois magie moi j'ai vu un athlète
sambre à faire un kilomètre départ
arrêté et faire un chrono que je ne n'ai
jamais été capable de réaliser et voilà
c'est ultra impressionnant
j'ai un respect et une admiration sans
borne pour tous tous ces athlètes et est
ce que je trouve ce que je trouve bien
en plus dans l'actualité récente pas
nécessairement uniquement des jo
paralympiques mais c'est que on a on a
là on ad on a des tranches de vie parce
que je trouve que jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à il ya une dizaine vingtaine
d'années c'était souvent des handicapés
de naissance qui est qui devenait qui
devenait athlètes paralympiques ou
athlètes à tête handicapés et kiki
performer dans tous les sports et là on
a des histoires des histoires et suis-je
rejoint yens sur le côté espoir et sur
le côté expérience avec des accidentés
de la vie des accidentés de la route et
qui qui change de sport ou qui se
mettent à des sports en
10 j'ai un exemple je n'ai pas retrouvé
le nom de cette de cette jeune femme qui
est tombée je crois que c'est à cheval
et qui essayent plusieurs sports andy
d'arrêt qui essaie de trouver son de
trouver son nouveau slogan et puis ce
jeune nageur là qui va traverser le lac
titicaca avec avec une amputation des
quatre membres
je trouve que c'est une leçon permanente
de mental de résilience et de et de
motivation de performance là ou là où le
sport fait vivre
désormais canet et vous pensez-vous que
de ce mois dans la dimension il ya
autour noir je le paie sur un 26 pays
cinq continents qui viennent en voisins
le bretonneux ça aurait dû être
organisée au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines finalement c'est
organisé à un voisin bretonneux à cause
du colis 19 parce que les locaux étaient
réquisitionnés pour pour le vaccin
qu'est ce que vous en pensez tout ça m'a
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui a été
dit sur ces athlètes qui nous donne des
leçons de vie oui les plus gros accident
de la vie ne vont pas vous arrêter on
peut toujours se relever et et moi je
retiens aussi la dimension paralympiques
on est bien sûr à deux ans et demi de
ces jeux olympiques mais aussi jeux
paralympiques de paris 2024 avec une
délégation française en plus sur le
tennis de table qui a brillé lors des
dernières géo et 11 médailles deux en or
si je ne m'abuse et donc c'est bien de
voir aussi ce genre d'événement se
multiplier et en plus sur le territoire
des yvelines ça permet aussi de faire
monter cette effervescence qui va nous
animer dans deux ans et demi avec ces jo
il ya aussi des jeunes aussi qui
déclasse du territoire qui sont venus
les rencontrer voire un petit peu la
compétition c'est important aussi
d'inclure les jeunes du coup au projet
jean ba oui bien sûr vous outre le le
respect l'admiration vous devez avoir
pour ces sportifs à part entière qu'on
me disait
notre ami
c'est vrai que baisse on n'en parle pas
assez comme tout comme autre commun pas
mal de 2,2 de discipline mineure on en
parle souvent ici ce plateau mais c'est
vrai que avec les performances qu'ils
ont pu faire aux derniers jeux
paralympiques
je pense qu'ils avaient largement leur
place à ce qu'on en parle un petit peu
plus et qu'on médiatise un petit peu
plus et ce genre d'événement est
on est très très très très bon pour eux
je trouve juste dommage que ce soit un
mardi mercredi jeudi
en effet c'est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué pour se déplacer quand 2 1
pour public voilà pour venir les voir
bruce scolaire par contre 1 qui les voit
très bien parce qu'ils ont plus miser
sur les scolaires que sur le public sur
un week-end je passe et
les clauses novembre à
paris
c'est votre petit bémol ouais c'est
juste revenu de vaches et on a on a
toujours cette
d'enlever la projection que qu'il mérite
tout simplement voilà on quand on fait
les jeux les jeux paralympiques taku de
la couverture médiatique des jeux
paralympiques n'est pas la même que le
pôle jeux olympiques même si ça
s'améliore grandement mais voilà là on
va leur arriver un tournoi et on va le
faire en semaine wen lors d'un tournoi
international plutôt boudé leur laisse
cuire de le faire sur un week-end où il
y aurait pu avoir très peu de
spectateurs là ils assurent un petit peu
mais on est la mer à travers les
scolaires moi je trouve que c'est un
match sur trois jours tous les cas le
vendredi samedi dimanche et en leur
parlant et on est dans cette dynamique
de paris 2024 où on mise énormément sur
la jeunesse on dit que c'est la
génération de 1024 c'est aussi avec ces
jeunes qu'il faut construire ces jeux
pour avoir une pleine réussite dans deux
ans et demi avant de passer au programme
de l'émission je vous propose de
regarder juste l'image d'une athlète
c'est une roumaine une athlète roumaine
voilà là
elle est handicapée du coup elle joue
avec des petits bras qu'est ce que ça
vous fait vous pierre challier de avoir
servi tout où l'on peut quand on veut
quand on veut on peut c'est encore une
fois c'est lui c'est bien choisi son
héros plus donc cesser cette cette
formidable preuve que que le mental peut
prendre le dessus quand le physique est
déficient par exemple quelle que soit la
raison accident ou de naissance etc
c'est un formidable message d'espoir
pour toutes les participations par les
olympiques on parle coubertin on parle
participer seat est là non seulement ils
participent mais ils performent y gagne
et il montre à quel point à quel point
le le corps humain même meurtrier est
fantastique on parlait de cet athlète
égyptiens qui nous mêmes avec sa bouche
donc comme quoi avec la volonté de la
force de caractère qu'ils ont ils sont
capables de repousser des montagnes et
de continuer à faire leur sport alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler golf l'open de france va
revenir au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines ce sera en septembre
2022 coup de projecteur également dans
cette émission sur à florian rousseau
l'ancien pistard triple champion
olympique vient d'être nommé directeur
du programme olympique à la ffc mais
avant de développer ces thèmes on va
parler voile
[Musique]
on va donc parler voilà une mauvaise
nouvelle sur la transat jacques vabre
pour notre évinois à louis burton le
skipper originaire de rambouillet déjà
abandonné avec son bureau vallée trois
seulement à 10 heures après le départ du
havre le 7 novembre son bateau a démâté
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche mais
rassurez vous ils ne sont pas blessés
ils ont pu rejoindre le port de
saint-malo 24 heures après l'incident on
écoute louis burton et davy beaudart
à la table à cartes et enfin de faire
l'âne à nous préparer la gestion de la
paie dans l'avenir
là on
[Musique]
oui il ya un petit bruit qui ne permet
pas
l'important comme un mise en place de
mais en place de boot comme ça arrive
très régulièrement et
et moins values
au crack heures grosse explosion
et ça fait vraiment
là c'est assez angoissant il ya
nrj12 en carbone
la ronce précipitent
[Musique]
sur la tête pour un reflex et
le matin
là on compte pour la démat et maintenant
chroniqueur on va réparer tout ça et qui
on va plus fort
déjà une réaction par rapport à cet
abandon le plus important c'est
peut-être qu'ils ne soient pas blessés
j'en sais non résidents c'est surtout le
principal n'est pas de blesser a pris
dans la verra petit
bureau
vous qui suis un petit peu il ya de la
voile sur ses déceptions section section
complet parce que
je pensais vraiment qu'ils aient les dix
premières heures de course vous avez
bien montré déjà qu'ils étaient dans le
musée d'un coup occupé la seconde place
du classement y ait de la catégorie
imoca glaciation ouais mais c'est vrai
que que c'est vrai des déçus j'allais me
quand j'ai eu la nouvelle je pensais
médiateur faut jamais regarder ou est-ce
que où est-ce qu'ils en sont
pas de boxe m'a très droit je me voilà
alors l'avantagé koala et était en route
pour saint malo du coup j'en fais le
havre saint pierre
c'est dommage il ya plein de mots de
vocabulaire qui me viennent balle aux
agents si c'est tout ça à la fois ça
fait il a fait des années qu'ils se
préparent chaque année chaque année
pendant lieu de longs moments de longs
mois pour ces courses là là les
conditions étaient assez assez forte sur
le départ le départ du havre mais elles
le sont pour tout le monde donc il y
avait il y avait une bonne brise
voilà il n'y a pas de véracité quelque
15 jours devant je rajoute
incompréhensible sur des sur des sur des
mécaniques comme ça je si j'ose dire
c'est hallucinant qu'un quart maquens à
la base au bout de obou 2000 c'est
d'ailleurs il sait toujours pas ce qui
s'est passé hier à grégory c'est ça moi
le mot qui me vient c'est
incompréhension effectivement bon je
suis archi déçu et parce que on
attendait beaucoup de louis burton son
départ aussi caser un top cinq en dix
villes à s'inquiéter
avant le départ 5e en 2013 c'est son
meilleur résultat incompréhension c'est
cette caste sur un bateau en plus ce qui
est tout récent il l'a acquis juste
après le vendée globe il avait fait un
vendée globe ce bateau avec eux avec
armel tripon et pour le moment et bien
il faudra que toute la lumière soit
faite sur sur cette casse on sait on
sait absolument pas ce qui s'est passé
le bruit 20 minutes avant après ce bruit
d'explosion qui a entendu
il faudra il faudra faire toute la
lumière sur sûr sur cette casse ça
paraît assez ça me choque pas un le
carbone quand ça pète ça pète ça ne
s'est bougé d'un coup sûr quand le
carbone carbone il a exposé après que le
moment au moment de la fracture le
carbone ça explose nous en vélo on voit
régulièrement les fibres voix sont
tellement résistante que bat pour que ça
casse il faut vraiment une très grosse
soir donc au moment où ça ça ça pète ça
fait toujours passer quelque chose avant
pour vous je suis pas je suis pas soucié
du carbone et je n'étais pas sur le
bateau donc je ne peux pas vous dire
qui a su renaître le maquis et derrière
kick ass est à la base lorsque je pense
que il
ils en parleront très naturellement et
on aura les honneurs à zinfos par la
suite mais pour l'instant il faut être
fou a analysé la seule chose que l'on
peut se dire c'est c'est du sport
mécanique de toute façon à partir du
moment où vous avez la mécanique un tour
de france ça peut se perdre sur une
crevaison bâle a en effet une fois que
vous avez cassé le moteur c'est
suffisamment grave pour qu'il ne puisse
pas repartir avec la vraiment c'est
l'abandon dans le premier premier jour
ils peuvent pas ils peuvent parler pas
il ya des questions à tout le temps
après dans toutes les gammes par un
chant fusion de deux des trois semaines
peut-être qu'il serait pas forcément
retourner pour réparer son bateau
peut-être en sépare le whisky est bête
c'est que ça arrive dès le début ils
étaient entre la pointe du cotentin et
l'île de guernesey donc on est vraiment
sur les tout débuts de cette course quoi
mais ils viennent juste de passer
l'espagne 1 ce matin j'ai regardé il
arrive
la question sur ce thème ce coup dur
métier en question le projet vendée
globe 2024 de louis burton oui ou non
vous êtes unanime
gens ça peut donner
non non c'est ça fait partie de la
course
je préfère la casse la case et fait
partie de la course et à la limite
j'irai guillaume utile qui veut ça lui
arrive sur cette course là que sur le
vendée globe ou vos donc
ou qu'ils pensent qu'il a il a plus il a
plus il investit plus pour cette course
le vendée globe que pour celle là ça là
c'était plus une cause d'entraînement
pour son nouveau bateau donc non stand
est entre guillemets la plus facile peut
être entre la route du rhum la transat
jacques vabre 802 les sont souvent des
crises sociales la preuve il n'y a pas
de course facile la preuve en est voyez
là ils sont les départs petacchi le
maquis qui se casse donc non non et pas
de course facile mais bon
techniquement ça peut ça peut être une
très belle expérience vous faites
peut-être qu'il y aura des ingénieurs et
était et des têt qui vont qui seront pas
au départ du vendée globe qui vont pas
retravailler sur le bateau mais ça fait
ça fait une expérience une expérience
pour ça m'a dit j'espère qu'ils sauront
ce qui s'exhale pas tout va bien on fait
le point de faiblesse le point de
faiblesses
identifiées pour pouvoir justement
réparer
vendée globe 2012 vendée globe 2012 où
il percute un chalutier ça n'a pas
empêché de se remettre tout de suite en
selle de repartir d'après sur une
cinquième place du bateau oui bonjour m
sur son voilier voilà ça à la barre et
le land l'année d'après en 2013 il filme
5e place sur la transat jacques vabre
dont qu'il a il a prouvé par le passé
avec moins d'expérience qui pouvait se
remettre vite en ordre de marche et donc
là je pense que avec cet objectif vendée
globe qui ont c'est dans un coin de sa
tête c'est ce qu'ils valent animé sur
les prochaines années il va repartir au
plus vite d'ailleurs ils sont déjà sûrs
dans les ateliers pour retravailler sur
le bateau le réparer voir ce qui s'est
passé au niveau du main ils veulent
participer à la route du rhum en
novembre 2008 donc il on a à peu près un
an pour préparer le bateau dans quel
état d'esprit sont les partenaires à
votre avis notamment bureau vallée
alors je rappelle un peu l'historique
ils ont investi entre 4 et 5 millions
d'euros pour acheter un nouveau bateau
le bateau de l'occitane en provence
d'armel tripon un nouveau bateau 4 à 5
millions premières roses course le
maquis casse à votre avis dans quel état
d'esprit il ya du jury c'est un
partenariat c'est pas ça se fait pas sur
voile alors ils sont partis sur trois
ans en effet bon casse à la première et
comme je vous dis je préfère qu'ils
cassent à la première plutôt que plutôt
qu'à la dernière on pourrait se dire
tout va bien et en fait on voit même pas
là on va même pas le pot-aux-roses à
l'aller ça serait quand même vraiment
dommage donc là
pour moi c'est pas les partenaires il
n'y a pas de dégâts pas il n'y a pas de
souci et au contraire ça va être une
très grosse expérience et s'il faut
mettre de couche de carbone de plus et
bien ils mettront en deux couches de
terrebonne de plus sur le prochain mois
là pour apporter votre question le mot
je dirais chaque fois peut-être encore
un peu chafouin sur ce moment là
en disant que ces arbres delà de
l'investissement l'effet des mesures
c'est un bateau pour potentiellement
faire un top3 sur le dernier le clochard
vendée globe est clairement mais c'était
c'était s'était affiché comme tel et il
a là encore je pense qu'il faut il faut
rétropédaler même s'ils ont du vélo et
puis faire et même sur nos bateaux par
et puis et puis tirait les tirs et les
expériences les enseignements techniques
de ducasse pareil d'une guigne le
goulding paris est favori du vendée
globe l'année dernière il n'a pas vu le
cap horn
c'était
alors il voulait racheter un bateau en
ce bateau d'armel tripon il voulait
racheter surtout pour pouvoir faire un
maximum de courses sur les quatre années
qui viennent plutôt que d'en construire
un pour ce que c'était la bonne
stratégie est ce que l'histoire
finalement
tu peu vécu il doit peut-être pu se
poser la question de construire son
propre bateau ou pas vous c'est sûr que
là maintenant et
quand on voit les problèmes du tout
qu'on dit que c'est mal mais c'est sûr
que maintenant que ça a cassé on se dit
pourquoi il n'a pas construit son bateau
non je pense qu'il faut pas tout
remettre en question parce que c'est une
erreur enfin c'est une erreur non
institue une cause d'une cause je cause
causes mécaniques donc on ne faut pas
tout remettre en question son qui
continuent là dessus et puis encore une
fois vous l'avez dit ils ont un an la
bourse peau se remette au poids pour la
course du rhum de 2022 donc je pense
qu'il est il est simplement cette course
là où malheureusement mais il n'est pas
allé loin donc je crois que jusqu'à la
provo prochain vendée globe il y aura il
aura d'autres d'autres d'autres
possibilités de s'exprimer et il va pas
casser à chaque fois ou alors c'est
vraiment la guigne à ce moment-là siro
casse faut qu'il le vende 9 brad
innovant qui a déjà fait un tennis il a
consacré un tour du monde plus fort il
avait accusé voilà six bien six morts
le pression précédents bateaux sont
exacts mais j'ai aussi le rachat d'ing
un pnb de mémoire un truc comme ça le
précédent bateau bureau vallée de zettel
willy l'ancien bateau d'armes et de
clash généralement ils rachètent se fait
beaucoup dans le milieu de la voile il
rachète l'un des meilleurs bateaux de la
flotte sur les filles ont précédente
avait gagné l'édition précédente il y
avait fait évoluer et parce que mine de
rien il avait été plus vite aussi il
avait amélioré sur le papier l'un des
bateaux les plus rapides du dernier
vendée globe
dernière question est ce que il y aura
peut-être l'occasion de mettre la
pression sur ses rivaux ses potentiels
rivaux pour le vendée globe pierre
chevallier il il a une expérience de
retenue il a il a une expérience de
toute façon maintenant ça commence à ne
plus être un perdreau de l'année
il a il a eu quelques bons résultats
qu'on a commenté souvent ici
donc je pense par l'envié je pense pas
c'est tout le monde voit de toute façon
c'est dit c'est une espèce davari davari
malchanceuse pour le coup il le dit déjà
il a je pense qu'il les a
donc il y reviendra plus fort d'un
charlie dalin par exemple ils risquent
de gagner non point dans ma l'ascendant
peut-être qu'on peut aussi voir la chose
dans l'autre sens c'est que ayant très
vite abandonné là ils vont peut-être
moins latentes sur les prochaines
courses et il va nous surprendre encore
une fois et et oui effectivement au
louis burton maintenant et est attendu à
chaque course là on l'annonçait comme
potentiel favori avec d'alain avec aussi
yannick bestaven le dernier vainqueur du
vendée globe donc il sera attendu à
chaque fois là c'est une grosse
déception donc on verra on verra mais je
pense que il l'a montré en plus dans les
mots qu'on a pu entendre il et il est
prêt à repartir tout de suite de l'avant
en tout cas louis burton devrait prendre
le départ de la route du rhum en
novembre 2000 22 s'il arrive à réparer
son bateau mais on imagine que oui on
imagine alors après une mauvaise
nouvelle une bonne nouvelle la nouvelle
a été officialisée début novembre l'open
de france de golf sera bel et bien de
retour en 2022 sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
plus ancien l'open d'europe continentale
avaient été annulés ces deux dernières
années à cause de l'épidémie de kobe 19
le tournoi se disputera cette fois ci du
22 au 25 septembre mais aura une
dotation de 3 millions d'euros le double
de la dernière édition organisée en 2019
ce qui pourrait attirer des joueurs de
renom l'écoutent pascal grizot le
président de la fédération française de
golf il était évidemment ravi
c'est un travail d'équipé comme vous le
savez c'est très important pour la
fédération française de golf de faire
revenir l'open de france au calendrier
nous avons une super dates en septembre
et sur le saut de sendai c'est aussi à
la même date que nous avons eu l'honneur
de la ryder cup en 2018
l'open de france 2022 soral la 104e
édition du tournoi de la dix neuvième
consécutive à se jouer au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la question
sur ce thème un vrai route est ce que
c'est un vrai retour en force de l'open
de france de golf cette annonce oui pour
vous pierre chevallier non
grégory non gens et non pour vous
également yann dujarrier ont fait un
petit duel entre vous grégory et pierre
cas vous commencez vous êtes seul contre
tous le sens et je suis contre tout j'ai
je fais la parenthèse pour vous c'est un
vrai retour envoie sa route ou
renforcent parce que je ferme je ferme
après l'avoir vécu de l'intérieur la
parenthèse qu'ovide on a on avait un
gros fonction d'événements après
l'édition 2019 qui était à la fois la
remise en cause de la place de l'open de
france dans le paysage des tournois
mondiaux de golf le retrait d'un
partenaire majeur déjà déjà acté et puis
le le problème de le problème de trouver
une date pour le pour le tour européen à
travers à travers un calendrier qui
était déjà bien chargé et l'open de
france notre open notre open national
est le plus vieux d'europe continentale
relégué au tournoi de seconde zone parce
que il y avait d'autres enjeux d'autres
enjeux à ce moment là et donc on a en
plus après essuyé des choix dans la date
qui était difficile notamment sur
octobre avec avec une tentative qui a
été qui s'est un peu soldée par le peu
de public autour et puis retour en juin
alors que habituellement c'était c'était
en juillet donc la crise qu'ovide arrive
par dessus sein est là pour le coup là
tout tombe aux oubliettes mais là
la filière gulf et le est donc derrière
la fédération était était au boulot pour
pouvoir remettre rendre à l'open de
france la place de la paix ce qu'ils
méritent et quand je dis retour en force
et que c'est à la fois dans ses
perspectives là une bonne date en
septembre une très bonne date parce que
le le le
ses déboulés bonne météo pour jouer au
golf notamment c'est juste après les
championnats du monde amateurs qui
auront lieu quelques quelques jours
quelques semaines plus tôt toujours au
golf national aussi donc les gros coup
de projecteur sur le sur le golf
français et en france pardon sur le golf
en france en espérant qu'ils aient
beaucoup de joueurs le français qui
arrivent c'est pendant la président cup
dont il ya aussi on aura peut-être
peut-être moins d'américains c'est sur
wii donc soir pour préciser c'est un ton
un peu comme la ryder cup entre les
états unis et le reste du monde
devraient sauf l'europe voilà et donc
donc ça veut dire que pour les européens
ont peut-être avoir justement un plateau
très intéressant pour succéder à nicolas
colsaerts derrière donc en gros ce bruit
retour en france parce que c'est un
retour au calendrier international avec
une dotation qui qui est substantiel et
qui étiez pour le coût à 3 millions 1,1
des plateaux les plus intéressants des
tournants du tour européen la gorge
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous avez un
spécialiste en phase devait commencer
par un petit retour en arrière l'édition
2010 cette édition 2010 8 tommy
fleetwood qui remporte l'édition 2010
est alexander noren l'édition 2018 on
est quelques semaines avant cette ryder
cup qui a été un peu l'apogée de
l'exposition ce golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on espère que
ça va revenir bien sûr avec les jeux
olympiques 2024 et puis depuis j'ai
l'impression que cet open de france
c'est un peu le lot peine poissard c'est
à dire cette perte de ceux du statut de
rolex séries avec la perte du sponsor
est chaîné l'opl le sponsor chinois
cette date en octobre qui avaient été
trouvés où on souvient et bien d'une
météo très capricieuse et on était un an
après la ryder cup était tout simplement
voilà la météo d'octobre et depuis bien
deux annulations une première fois on
avait dit je me rappelle avec jean qui
était en visio lors de cette émission on
avait parlé du du report de de cette
édition qui était prévu en mai à 6 je te
montrerai replay genre on avait mis
cette édition de l'open de france en mai
cette année finalement ça a été reporté
on se réjouissait de cette date de mai
au début parce que elle intervenait
peut-être elle est un peu original dans
ce calendrier ou l'open de france
essayait de se trouver justement une
date pour s'installer il y avait la date
de juin qui fonctionnait très bien
pendant une vingtaine d'années je crois
sur sur la date de juin 19 sa venue
aurait été la dernière semaine de juin
pendant pendant plusieurs années il va
une vingtaine d'années ou fin juin début
juillet pourquoi je dis que c'est pas un
retour en force parce que eh bien on re
balade une nouvelle fois cet open de
france avec une nouvelle date là ça va
être sur la fin septembre or fin
septembre niveau météo au niveau de
l'exposition dans le calendrier c'est
bien sauf que les années de ryder cup et
bien il y aura pas d' open de france
puisque ça va se dérouler si je dis pas
de bêtises sur les périodes de ryder cup
en 2023 est exactement la perte de la
ryder cup en 2023 quid bonita sept
opérateurs c'est allé voir l'italie
d'ailleurs il est sur deux une année sur
deux on va dépend plus en italie au
marco simone et voilà à rome c'est dire
que c'est pas le même seven oui c'est
malheureux mais c'est toi le footballeur
l'ancien footballeur ça veut dire que
quoi une année sur deux on va re décalé
une nouvelle fois l'open de france on
souhaite l'installer et que ça devienne
une date for une à nouveau de ce
calendrier européen enfin moi j'ai du
mal à y voir j'ai juste une petite
question là sur la tête du mois de mai
qui avait été annoncé pierre chevalier
avait dit quoi grégory est ce que vous
savez s'il avait dit que c'était une
excellente date parce qu'il a dit que
c'est en était la meilleure date a donc
lancé et
j'ai dit ces gens sur le fait que mais
c'était peut-être une bonne date pour
réinstaller et avant une nouvelle date
dans le calendrier européen sans grosse
concurrence parce que oui cette date
d'octobre on s'en était tous émus en
plateau voilà ça c'est juste un an après
la ryder cup on avait la gueule de bois
je pense que le mot est bien choisi
d'abord cet open de france en octobre
donc j'ai l'impression qu'on re balade
une nouvelle fois cette date donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une année sur
deux ou est ce que sera cet open de
france voilà je pose la question genre
qui vous a convaincu vous étiez dans
ceux du côté de grégory géant grand
regret c'est calme
non je suis d'accord avec lui j'avais
d'ailleurs j'étais d'accord depuis le
début pourquoi parce que on a
l'impression quand même que cette
compétition ils ont jamais le choix dans
la date qu on les provinces il l'a dit
greg grégory et mais c'est pour beaucoup
qui ne compte qu'une compétition ce soit
une grande compétition il faut que ce
soit toujours à la même date c'est comme
si on me promenais le tour de france un
coup à juillet un goût un coup en
janvier non là il ya eu un roland garros
au mois d'octobre on vient où on est et
coccinelles s'était fait débat rappelons
qu'au vide là c'était par rapport aux
convives non non ça c'était long mais
simplement là on a du mal et là je
rejoins à 100 pour ça parce qu'on a du
mal quand même hein quoi mais quoi alors
vous de voir ces juin que je vais
juillet après ça a été un long temps
après à mes lacets en septembre
finalement
c'est vince table quoi il faut suivre il
faut il faut suivre et d'autres
spécialistes peut-être non mais c'est
pas pour ça mais j'ai pas sa mère mais
pour moi une grande compétition a
toujours lieu à la même date a toujours
la même date tous les ans à la même date
parce que les gens s'organisent autour
d'une belle compétition comme ça et il
est vrai que la date idéale était celle
qui a été pendant 19 ans celle de fin
juin début juillet où la bête tout le
monde de s'y retrouver alors je ne sais
pas pourquoi je suis pas dans les
instances où quoi il l'homme déplacer et
redéplacer mais là on se contacte le
peut maintenant j'ai l'impression pour
pierre chevallier l'eau à votre moulin
quand même c'est que on se se placent
sur les compétitions internationales de
golf par rapport majeur aux quatre
majeurs et en l'occurrence là ça serait
donc c'est les majors sont passés il y
avait un problème lorsqu'il ya un seul
problème lorsque le lorsque l'open était
sur fin juin début juillet c'était la
proximité de l'open britannique qui
pouvait être un avantage parce qu'il y
avait certains américains où certains
certains européens qui étaient déjà sur
site pour aller jouer après en grande
bretagne mais en général il y avait
quand même pas mal de pas mal de délai
entre les deux et donc du coût des
tournois entre entre les deux et là on a
peut-être je dis bien peut-être là la
date au moins septembre
septembre au sens large avec avec la
prise en considération de la ryder tous
les tous les deux ans world plutôt tous
les quatre ans quand sept en europe
parce que quand tu sais quand c'est en
nous aux etats unis le on va dire le le
oui la confrontation en fait des deux
événements n'est pas exactement la même
mais donc on a peut-être trouvé en
septembre au moins ce créneau où ce
créneau qui fait que c'est à la fois
jouable c'est bien pour tout ce qui est
hospitalisé c'est bien pour le public
toujours au golf national sur ce stadium
avec avec un mois de septembre était
indien ça peut ça peut donner des images
assez spectaculaires dont le golf a
besoin au même titre qu'un champion
français ou où les porte-drapeaux
internationaux date où il ya une jarre y
est ce que vous allez changer d'avis
vous savez j'avais dit non tout
simplement parce que mes pieds pire à
pouvoir faire de
la question étant est ce que c'est un
retour flamboyant ou un retour en force
déjà pour pouvoir revenir fois une
partie et je suis désolé pendant les
deux années où il n'a pas été jouer
alors qu'il devait être même fait dans
le sud de la france bah il n'a pas été
fait et elle est localisée sur le golf
de terreblanche ça dans le var moi je
n'ai pas pour moi ce n'est même pas un
retour en force par contre peu le point
positif que je veux je vois quand même
c'est en effet cette augmentation de dot
qui va permettre de revaloriser en euros
qu'il a permis de revaloriser et deux et
de prendre
le pouvoir et
mais voilà là il ya vraiment un point un
point important maintenant voilà c'est
vrai que le point sur la ryder cup pour
moi il me fait pas peur non plus c'est à
dire que on vient justement de le
souligner une fois tous les quatre ans
eh ben ça fera venir les américains
aussi donc si on avance d'une semaine
dans n'aura peut-être plus d'américains
qui viendront avec plaisir au golf
national parce que ils ont aimé ce aimé
se jouer et puis ben ils enchaîneront la
semaine suivante allait faire la ryder
cup donc ça peut même être un point
positif pour poursuivre il se posera le
problème de une année sur quatre
quand et là ce sera plus un tournoi pour
les européens et puis et puis et puis
basta voilà c'est pas ce n'est pas grave
ce méga qu'une seule je prends l'exemple
du cyclisme il ya que lors du tour de
france qu'il y a quasiment aucune course
pour les autres professionnels pendant
quand vous avez là le giro vous avez
d'autres vous avez d'autres d'autres
courses pendant la vuelta vous avez
aussi une très belle course très belle
course à côté donc c'est pas ce n'est
pas un problème de d'avoir des
compétitions annexes lors de très grands
événements en tout cas voilà on attend
cette date de septembre fin septembre
2022 dans un an à peu près 1 voilà avec
impatience on passe maintenant notre
page débats
[Musique]
on va maintenant passer à l'envolée de
grégory le moment le plus spectaculaire
de ce 6 de ceux ci en parler sport de
quoi allez vous nous parlez grégory de
cyclisme avec du mouvement à la
fédération française le 3 novembre
dernier depuis le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines où elle est
installée l'instance a officialisé la
nomination de florian rousseau comme
directeur du programme olympique de
cyclisme un poste tout fraîchement créée
en vue de paris 2024 ou emmanuel macron
a fixé un objectif de 80 médaille rien
que ça pour la délégation française
s'est investie de l'eau c'est facile ce
sera facile pour pour la délégation
française alors florian rousseau à la
ffcc un retour un pour lui un point
l'ancien pistard entraîneur national est
du pool sprint à l'insep de 2005 à 2013
dernièrement il était le directeur de la
haute performance à la fédération
française d'athlétisme avant sa
démission en septembre dernier la
mission de florian rousseau tout
simplement préparer l'échéance de 2024
avec un suivi de l'ensemble des
disciplines cyclistes cyclisme sur route
et sur piste vtt et bmx mon rôle c'est
d'animer de coordonner en tout cas est
de fixer un cap pour notamment par
rapport aux objectifs de réussite donc
deux médailles aux jeux en paris 2024
d'identifier les besoins pour
accompagner les entraîneurs les acteurs
de la terre fait
les athlètes la plus value est vraiment
transformé l'essai lors des jeux
olympiques pour ça évidemment il va
construire son approche il va la
construire avec l'encadrement il va
mettre en place une équipe pour gérer
tous les aspects qui lui semble
important autour de la performance c'est
plein d'éléments qui vient de s'agréger
les uns aux autres et c'est tout ce
travail de construction qui doit
l'amener à faire en sorte que à paris de
1024 dons soit dans une configuration où
on confirme finalement les résultats
qu'on a dans les grands championnats
internationaux
ma première réaction à l'annoncé de
cette réaction je me suis dit enfin
enfin un grand champion pour guider la
jeune génération dont on a dit assez ici
en plateau avec elle avait beaucoup de
mal à franchir un cap chez les grands
après les jo tokyo raté pour le cyclisme
deux médailles de bronze sur piste et
rien d'autre florian rousseau va pouvoir
faire profiter de son expérience
internationale et de son vécu et qu'elle
vécut j'ai envie de vous dire trois
médailles d'or olympiques en kilomètres
à atlanta en 1996 en keirin et en
vitesse par équipes à sydney 2000 où il
avait aussi glané une médaille d'argent
en vitesse individuelle sans parler de
ses 10 titres de champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste c'est l'un des
palmarès les plus garnis dans sa
discipline l'une des légendes même du
cyclisme sur piste et rier il ya du jard
hier bien sûr bien sûr qu'ils ne
l'oublient pas on l'oublié pas mais
cette nomination intervient seulement en
novembre 2000 21 nous sommes à deux ans
et demi des jeux de paris florian
rousseau le reconnaît lui-même son plein
il va être très serré dans les prochains
jours dans les prochains mois l ancien
pistard doit rencontrer les entraîneurs
les sélectionneurs pour construire une
vision commune ne fallait-il pas et bien
faire cette nomination beaucoup plus tôt
c'est toute la question vous souvenez
vous messieurs quand est-ce que a été
officialisé l'organisation des jeux de
paris et 7 ans enfin ça qu'aujourd'hui
mais il ya cinq ans c'était en quelle
année 2010 est exactement 13 décembre 13
septembre 2017 c'était donc il y à il ya
plus de quatre ans une année plus tôt
les jo de rio avait été déjà un fiasco
pour les bleus une seule médaille de
bronze en piste avec la vitesse par
équipes et on se souvient en plus de
l'ambiance délétère de l'époque et nommé
un directeur du programme olympique dès
2017 n'aurait pas été illogique
plus de temps pour travailler avec en
plus un galop d'essai entre temps avec
ces jo de tokyo en 2020 j'en suis
convaincu un florian rousseau peut
amener une plus value à une plus value
non négligeable pour la délégation
française de cyclisme ménès déjà pas
trop tard j'en ai bien peur la question
sur cette thématique est ce que c'est
trop tard ou pas oui ou non
c'est de partager les rugbymans
alors on est alors pourquoi j'en conçois
vous êtes très partagés parce que
peut-être que spécialiste
c est
quand même
non pourquoi pourquoi je suis items
parce que ben oui parce que je suis je
suis pas maître de la de la discipline
maintenant on a quand même affaire à
quelqu'un qui remplit toutes les cases
c'est sportivement du haut niveau du
très haut niveau grégory rappeler son
palmarès au niveau encadrement il a
montré il a montré ce qu'ils savaient
faire parce qu'on n'a jamais eue
tu arrêtes si je me trompe mais autant
de bons résultats quand il était
entraîneur du sprint j'aurais aimé que
grégory reste la recherche parce que en
effet jeunes voilà pour moi la passe
juste si j'étais rue ou pas donc vous
mois atteint 4 nerfs et d'avril approuvé
ce qui est dit il était capable
et maintenant on le met à la tête de ce
projet mais et c'est vrai pour non plus
que positif sur le papier si leur
objectif sur le papier mais c'est vrai
que là on est à dire à deux ans et demi
qu à deux ans et demi à es22 grofin
trois en tout cas il ya deux ans et demi
je trouve que c'est un petit peu tardif
parce que ou alors on le prend pour un
magicien et puis on veut dire
j'espère qu'on la voit pas au charbon en
tout cas parce que ce serait ce serait
regrettable mais la tâche ne sera pas
facile parce que tout ne se fait pas
comme ça d'un coup de baguette magique
et pour moi il aurait fallu un peu plus
de temps alors pour la défense de la
façon française donc c'est le dtn un qui
voulait le nommer il voulait nommer dès
janvier 2021 donc janvier dernier il
voulait nommer mais problème c'est que
les jeux olympiques ont été décalés et
du coup ne pouvait pas annoncer sa
nouvelle recrue on va dire avant les jo
donc il a attendu tous assurent déjà
mais voilà ce n'est soit des problèmes
en interne ça le résultat est là jusqu'à
ce qu'il ait nommé là maintenant et que
ça fait pour moi un petit un peu tardif
car chevalier tant que deux heures ce
métal que ce
spécialiste sur ce plateau je dirai
juste une chose c'est qu'on dirait il y
ressemble il ressemble à jean après
trois semaines de régime comme j'aime ça
et pour le coup quand on te voit comme
ça avec eux florian rousseau utiliser le
même à bkc le même
c'était tout c'est ça mon analyse voilà
je dirais on saura si c'est trop tard
en juillet 2024
je n'en fais pas maintenant
en effet florian c c'est quelqu'un qui
est spécialiste qui est très très sympa
qui a une aura
dans le dans le domaine du cyclisme
maintenant attention on le met à la tête
du
de toutes les disciplines c'est à dire
qu'il va falloir
la vie sur la route
est-ce qu'il est légitime pour aller
donner des conseils à un vététiste alors
après leicester la fédération française
d'athlétisme justement est ce qu'il est
et justin dans ce cas là excusez moi
mais les résultats à la clé je te faire
un peu l'avocat du diable mais instable
attelé cette année ils sont pas là non
plus donc est ce que un directeur de la
performance après la question moi je
vous pose c'est quel est le rôle du
directeur de performance voilà
de faire performer mais le dtn il est là
le dtn il est là pourquoi alors
l'entraîneur national il est là pourquoi
je hais ce qui ferait pas le lien
peut-être entre entre tout ça dtn
entraîneur sportif
sincèrement je moi j'ai l'impression
qu'on rajoute et techniques ou est-ce
que son rôle et sur la préparation
mentale
énormément préparation mentale avec
parce que c'est peut-être pas sur le
côté technique de la discipline
sauf que je pense sincèrement que alors
là je vais parler du cyclisme sur piste
il y a un gros problème il ya une
refonte à faire sur la manière de se
préparer aujourd'hui quand on discute à
l'équipe quand on discute avec certains
athlètes on vous dit que on travaille
avec des méthodes qui sont intra
française et qui sont des méthodes qui
sont un peu peut-être dépassé ça fait
très longtemps qu'on reste avec des
coachs français et et ses problématiques
et dans d'autres sports on se pose aussi
la question maintenant pour moi l'image
de florian rousseau c'est le didier
deschamps du cyclisme voilà si gagner
pour moi flo larusso c'est le didier
deschamps du cyclisme
la plus-value mois moi je vois ce que je
disais à la fin de ma chronique la plus
value yves à la porte et ça j'en suis
persuadé maintenant on est quand même à
deux ans et demi des jo ça va arriver
très vite lui même l'a reconnu il va
devoir rencontrer tous les entraîneurs
tous les sélectionneurs quelques
athlètes pour construire une vision
commune à deux ans et demi des jo c'est
trop tard ça me paraît si
on regarde encore un petit peu
différemment là où on peut vraiment se
poser le point sur l'aspect
psychologique dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que j'en avais je
vais prendre un bus vtt chez les filles
on avait la numéro un et la numéro deux
mondiale au départ des jeux olympiques
et ont fait un constat les demandes et
épais fédération française de cyclisme
c'est qu'ils ont beaucoup de champions
du monde entre les olympiades ils ont
énormément de champion du monde mais le
problème c'est que le jour des geôles au
moment des jo sinon chaque médaille
juriste rêver joris daudet plusieurs
fois champion du monde en bmx équipe à
rennes n'arrive pas à aller chercher une
médaille olympique donc peut-être que en
effet le rôle de fleur ou sauce rassure
sera là dessus et ça sera vraiment sur
l'aspect mental nous pensons que c'est
possible qu'il fasse passer ce cap de
passer de champion du monde et champion
olympique ça remonte le sarm est un
assez loin les performances d'athlètes
de florian rousseau mais ça reste lui un
palmarès et une expérience sportive qui
en plus est allé se frotter à d'autres
sports où il n'était peut-être pas
légitime avec le résultat qu'on connaît
mais en tout cas c'est ça reste ça reste
un champion et qui s'est préparé comme
tel c'est qu'elle soit prendre quelqu'un
qui connaît parfaitement le cyclisme on
sait que ça se fait beaucoup dans
beaucoup de fédérations de prendre
quelqu'un qui vient de l'extérieur d'un
autre sport pour les mettre sur
parler ya quinze jours ici je pense que
c'est de cesser indispensable
indispensable de connaître la culture du
sport après là l'esprit de gagner les et
le mental peut peut se transposer à
n'importe quel sport et il faut quand il
faut quand même que c'est la leçon actif
c'est en gros d'inculquer l'esprit de la
gagne en fait
quand on regarde la fédération de
l'athlétisme les très belles années
qu'ils ont pu avoir il ya pas très
longtemps c'était avec l'ancien lutteur
ghani yalouz voilà excusez moi les non
gelée bouge tout le temps mais on est
d'accord mais mais mais c'est vrai que
l'été est là et là la clé a eu une belle
et des belles années donc sur des postes
de président je suis d'accord où ils
sont un peu dans une stratégie un peu
plus globale d'avancé mais sur les
postes techniques à mon sens il faut des
sportifs qui connaissent le sport c'est
moi ma conviction c'est d'espoir il ya
des sports qui ne pourraient pas qu'il
n'y aurait pas avoir des délais aux
spécialistes
aujourd'hui moi avec ma connaissance du
cycliste je sais qu'aujourd'hui je suis
capable d'accompagner mes enfants qui
font de l'athlétisme dans la performance
oui parce qu'il ya des il ya des
passerelles commune alors un petit
niveau le jo si jamais voilà un petit
niveau
les futurs champions olympiques c'est
comme ça dans le temps là donc dans
beaucoup de sports on a un technicien un
entraîneur et on a des préparateurs
mentaux donc elle dope ses voiles a
cessé il ya des gars des sports qui ne
souffre pas l'absence de techniques et
il ya également un dernier aspect aussi
cuit qui faut noter les jo de 2024 se
dérouleront à paris donc forcément plus
de pression qu'à tokyo bonjour plus de
pression et pour nous ça commence déjà
ça commence déjà la preuve les
répressions quelles sont les plantes et
non mais pour moi quand un peu partout
mental
on peut on peut ne pas être de la
discipline pour être un bon préparateur
mental mais pour moi on a le plus on a
le plus qui fait que lorsque on connaît
bien la discipline dont on parle et
bessat donnent le plus et c'est d'autant
plus que c'est un sport individuel et de
sueur sur cette différence du plus de la
connaissance profonde qu'a rousseau sur
la discipline il peut apporter ce plus
justement mentalement sur cette pression
qui va y avoir en 2024 à paris avec nos
champions donc je dis moi je dis que
c'est là que le temps c'est tout sinon
le leb appareils 6 ici n'ont cessé ils
pouvaient pas mieux aux bretons me
revoir et pour l'instant il n'y a pas
d'objectif de médailles ils
communiqueront dans les prochains mois
les prochaines années surtout pour voir
ce qui n'a pas fonctionné aux derniers
jo de tokyo game show potentiellement il
pourrait gagner 22 titres c'est ça on a
calculé en rigolant rédaction sur les 80
médaille annoncé par emmanuel macron si
on transpose ça fait une vingtaine pour
le cyclisme normalement on verra de
titres potentiels on sort des jo on sort
des yeux tokyo et aux championnats du
monde ben voilà on a fait des très bons
résultats donc hôtel que tu vois le
ruisseau va apporter cette expertise on
verra ça en tout cas dans les prochaines
années on va maintenant parler football
pour refermer ceux ci ont parlé sport le
week end du 7 novembre a été marqué par
le départ du président du club du fc
versailles 78 daniel voisin a décidé de
démissionner après à dix huit années à
la présidence du club malgré les très
bons résultats du club en nationale 2
avec une première place le dirigeant
explique être en désaccord avec
l'entraîneur du club youssef chibi ainsi
qu'avec les nouveaux investisseurs
arrivés au club au printemps dernier ces
désaccords l'ont amené à se retirer de
la vie du club je vous fais un peu à
l'historique de cette annonce daniel
voisin avait repris le club en 2004
alors que la structure avait de graves
difficultés financières
deux cent cinquante cinq mille euros de
déficit les premiers mois aujourd'hui à
ça va mieux et en 2021 le club de
football de versailles est décidé de
créer une sas société par actions
simplifiée avec comme principales
actionnaires et investisseurs le groupe
fit du sim city un promoteur immobilier
basé à versailles le budget du club a
été multiplié par 5 c'est désormais ce
groupe qui assurera la présidence la
question sur cette thématique est-ce que
ce départ est choquant oui ou non oui
pour vous pierre chevallier
vous êtes partagés vous êtes oui pour
tout le monde pourquoi vous êtes
partagés je pars choquant oui quand on
connaît le personnage qu'il a donné au
club effectivement daniel voisin il a
amené ce club de versailles vous l'avez
dit est très bien qui était en déficit
au moment où il l'a récupéré il était à
500 adhérents au moment il le récupère
aujourd'hui plus de 1200 adhérents qui
fait l'un des clubs avec le plus
adhérent en ile de france et même dans
la france entière donc oui c'est
choquant de voir ce personnage quitter
la tête de versailles après au vu des
derniers mois et des derniers événements
on sait que versailles a multiplié son
budget par cinq on sait que en interne
ça se passait plutôt mal avec avec les
nouveaux investisseurs qui étaient qui
est arrivé je le trouve moins choquant
qui quitte ses fonctions et que
justement il l'a dit dans l'interview
qui a été partagée sur la page facebook
du club finalement il reste fidèle à ses
convictions pour lui c'est d'abord il
faut d'abord être humble et il faut pas
perdre toute sa tête à cause de l'argent
voilà moi j'ai exactement gg les termes
je pense personnellement que l'on peut
et l'on doit à professionnaliser notre
club en respectant l'histoire et les
personnes qui la composent tout en
agissant avec un minimum d'humilité
après qu'il ait été poussé vers la
sortie j'en serais pas étonné aussi mais
le recul il à dire un conflit avec
l'entraîneur youssef chebbi qui
l'entraîneur du club depuis plusieurs
années qui a construit ce club de
versailles pour l'emmener le plus haut
possible et ce qui est choquant aussi
c'est au vu de la situation de
versailles qui sportivement en ce moment
versailles marche sur le onze journées 0
défaite 6 victoires 5 matches nul dans
cette poule de nationale 2 qui est
vraiment lancée sur de bons rails pour
monter en national donc c'est vrai que
ça intervient à un moment de la saison
où on s'y attendait pas forcément après
voilà c'est pas choquant parce qu'il
reste fidèle à ses convictions c'est en
tout cas ce qu'il dit dans le courrier
dans l'interview qui a été partagée sur
la page facebook du club pierre
chevallier je vois ça on oublie que la
serbie avait fermé par la fenêtre du
rugby versailles et puisque nous sommes
voisins
avec le foot est donc de donner le
voisin est ce que je trouve choquant
c'est surtout c'est surtout
effectivement la manière on parle en
interne
dans ce qui a pu fuiter de putsch il ya
de butch de du coup du coach et dans le
sillage d'une
bouleversement de cette société qui
avait investi sseurs qui d'un côté ils
font passer un cap budgétaire au club de
foot de versailles mais de l'autre
apporte des apporte des méthodes qui
n'étaient pas celles qui ont fait le
lustre du club de football de
de versailles vous avez vous avez
rappelé la citation d'allier l'oisans et
effectivement sur le on en parle
suffisamment dans le rugby par exemple
ces fameuses valeurs de valeur des
actions mais elles sont vraiment elles
sont présentes dans tous les sports y
compris dans le foot le foot à
versailles c'est mille deux cents
licenciés vous l'avez rappelé et c'est
une d une des sections sportives qui
tracte le sport à versailles qui au
départ n'est pas une ville estampillée
sportive qui est d'abord culturel mais
avec le maire m'a dit on et souffre on
est suffisamment au front pour pouvoir
au niveau de tous les sports performer
et avoir des résultats là il ya eu des
tours en coupe de france il ya quelques
années il ya les gars en place d'une
première place de leader incontesté en
national team tour de contrôle ans en
2018 avec une montée en potentiel en
national il ya un toit il ya des tours
deux tours de coupe de france qui arrive
7e je pense que je vais devoir refaire
les paris des paris je vois la sueur sur
les classes de nos club yvelinois en
coupe de france donc oui choquant parce
que parce que c'est en gros c'est
balayer d'un radar vers demain tout ce
qui a été fait au football ils sont très
bien installé à borj fontaine parfois
ils ont ils sont même ils sont même
n'est ni traités que d'autres sections
par exemple en termes de nombre de
terrains mais c'est comme ça on a on ne
tond traite une une section une section
à mille deux cents licenciés avec les
égards qu'elle mérite il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'oeuvres sociales qui sont
faites par le football à versailles et
donc oui c'est étonnant et c'est dommage
de voir et de voir de voir un pan
d'histoire de ce club partir comme ça
sur sur une espèce de sur une espèce de
d'oasis financier qui donnera certes des
moyens mais qui ne doit pas remettre
tout en question genre alors moi ça peut
vouloir réagir oui non parce que alors
généralement je crois que c'est
généralement c'est la teneur con
la sortie et non pas le président
lorsqu'il ya butch de l'un et l'autre
donc là déjà ça me sens ne surprend mais
après quand donc quand on connaît un
petit peu plus le sujet et il n'y a pas
matière tout simplement et vous l'avez
dit qu'ils ont multiplié le budget par
cinq en gros investisseurs arrivent les
méthodes l'entraîneur lui et paraît plus
patch plus pour ce nouvel investisseur
il les a dans la poche donc on va garder
l'entraîneur qui lui va va véhiculer
notre notre message il a sportivement il
a les résultats donc on va le garder par
contre on ne veut plus du monsieur qui
est arriérée et qui va nous bloquer dans
notre développement il est là le
problème le problème malheureusement
c'est l'argent et dans ce cas de figure
c'est criant multiplier par cinq le
budget donc ce président qui lui on a
rappelé je peux le refaire on a rappelé
tout ce qu'il a pu faire pour ce club là
maintenant et c'est pas excusez moi mais
c'est désolant quand le pouce comme ça
va la sortie ça respecter tout le
travail qu'il a pu faire n'est ce que et
ils ont déjà trouvé son successeur c'est
jean luc arribart qui devient le
directeur général du club a été choisi
par le groupe immobilier il a joué à
rennes à reims laisse nancy lorraine il
était aux commentaires sur eurosport
canal+ cette année il a participé aux
commentaires sur le jeu pes 6 aux côtés
de christian jeanpierre
quelqu'un d'assez médiatique je crois
que tu voulais rajouter quelque chose
juste une petite précision le club des
versets qui va continuer de fonctionner
sur deux aspects cette es16 que vous
avez évoqué effectivement jean luc
arribart en devient le directeur général
mais il ya toujours le volet associatif
qui existent et qui va perdurer et c'est
anthony perrin qui prend là la
présidence la suite de la présidence à
versailles en gros la ss va s'occuper
plus de l'équipe première alors que
l'association va garder le volet
formation parce que cette équipe arr
label élite désormais un label or aussi
côté féminin et on espère que ça va
perdurer puisque le travail de ces
dernières années on espère qu'il va pas
être jeté à la poubelle jarrier je veux
juste leur souhaiter de réussir à
atteindre nos objectifs parce que c'est
vrai que l'objectif ligue 2 or voilà l
objectif ligue 2 merci de ce que je vois
c'est ça le la finalité c'était d'aller
chercher la ligue 2 pas ce qu'on me
disait souvent c'est pas normal que dans
les yvelines on n'est pas alors le père
est psg voilà qui met on n'est pas un
vrai club yvelinois qu'ils puissent
qu'ils puissent être là sur la scène la
scène nationale française voilà et qui
nous permettrait de passer quelques
tours en coupe de france par la suite
c'est assez révélateur de la de la
partie médiatique la nouvelle partie
médiatique qui va être qu'il va se jouer
pour le pour le football à versailles
jean luc arribart est un choix un choix
fort en termes d'exposition notamment et
je pense qu'on reparlera souvent de lui
sur ce plateau ce campus est un très bon
golfeur
peut-être dans les prochaines émissions
et peut-être qu'on le verra peut-être tu
vas sur l'open de france et peut-être un
jour contrepartie il lit quasiment
chaque année là c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
on termine par une citation de l'ancien
tennisman yannick noah qui vit
d'ailleurs dans les yvelines nos limites
n'existent que dans l'eau crainte je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]